hello everyone welcome to today's light
broadcasts metabolomics and explore land
precision medicine presented by dr. John
riles
I'm Christina jewel of labyrinth and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational seminars presented
by labyrinth the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
have virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning for more information go to lab
rats comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can but
if we're unable to get to your question
they will be answered via email
following the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on this
green icon located in the lower right
now if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window first fit your problem through
the brain Q&A button on the lower left
this is an educational webinar and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the webinar is over please click
on the CD button located on the lower
left-hand corner of your webpage and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. John riles
dr. John riles co-founded matata 1
incorporated in 2002 and serves as
president and CEO Metabo man is a
pioneer and leader in the field of
metabolomics and its use and precision
medicine and human health
prior to McCollum he was a co-founder
CEO and president of paradigm genetics
incorporated a publicly traded
agricultural biotechnology company
focused on industrializing the process
of gene function discovery dr. Isles has
30 years experience in the biotechnology
industry including senior research
positions at Novartis and seebik IV he
currently serves on the board of
directors at add biome the provider of
early
stage R&D for agriculture and the
Advisory Board of the College of
Agriculture and life sciences at North
Carolina State University here in the BA
in biology and chemistry from the
University of North Texas and MS and PhD
degrees in molecular biology from the
University of Texas at Dallas please
join me in welcoming dr. John riles I
will now turn the presentation over to
him dr. Isles okay Thank You Christine
[Music]
Thank You Christine so today what I'd
like to talk about is what we're doing
at metallo and how we're developing
metabolomic technology and using that
really in helping to understand better
how the genome is is functioning but
also how you know how to better look at
human health and disease and you know
what we try to do with metabolite is for
it measure all the small molecules in a
sample all at the same time and so if
you want to put this in context if
you're looking at DNA or genomics and
you're trying to understand DNA
structure you try to understand the
mutations and in a person or individual
you know what you're getting them is
data on the risk that having you been
actually happening you know not all
mutations are penetrant they don't all
actually cause anything to happen and so
you're getting a risk assessment and
what we do at metabolite is look at the
small molecules that comprise of
metabolism and so when things are
happening you know when the genes are
causing differences or when you have
developing the disease what you're
actually changing are the small
molecules and that's why what we can
comprehensively measure so the way we do
this is through a mass spectrometry
method we use a number of different
methods to analyze a sample because
these molecules are very diverse no one
method is going to measure everything
and the trick to the technology you
can't just buy a mass spec and do what
we do at metabolites you know what
you'll end up getting is huge amounts of
data that you're not
be able to interpret and just to give
you an example if we take a water sample
and run it through these various
processes will create about 40,000 data
points per sample and those those data
points are called ion features
so that's your noise level that's how
much noise is coming through the system
and it's coming from things like
plasticizers through contaminants of
solvents things like that if we run a
plasma sample through this system will
create about 43,000 data points and so
the whole trick to this is data
processing and how do you separate
signal from noise and to approach that
we come at this mathematically and
through data processing method we've
written about two million lines of
software code where we collect that
information off of the detector in the
mass spectrometer and then from every
every manipulation or every calculation
of the date of the stone after that is
done in our software environment and so
very quickly we can go from a very
heavily noisy data set to eliminate that
noise zero in on the signal and then
associate those data points to the
actual molecules they represent and then
organize that into very organized ways
of looking at the data and so very
quickly we can go from a very noisy
sample to a very ordered set of
molecules and we can understand pathways
that are being involved in the disease
and we can use that information to
interpret not only why we're seeing
certain changes in metabolism but how
that links to physiology and we back
that up over the past 15 years with
about 5,000 independent studies we run
Studies on all kinds of different human
diseases all kinds of types of samples
and we've been able to then piece
together the overall metabolism and how
that really relates to physiology so
it's not just getting the biomarkers
getting the molecules but it's also
understanding what they do now when we
take that data from what we call our
global platform and we combine it with
data that we can get up our complex
lipid methods and I should say we
developed an instrument called the lipid
dies or we come
develop that with a B sigh X and it can
measure about a thousand lipids in a
blood sample so by combining those two
datasets and looking at a blood sample
say a plasma sample in humans we can
measure about two thousand molecules
that are being maintained homeostatic
alee in the plasma and a healthy person
so if you and among those molecules are
going to be about 250 molecules that are
derived from bacterial metabolism and so
as humans we have outsourced about 10
percent of our total metabolic
capability to the bacteria in our
intestines or in our gut and that's what
the gut microbiome does it actually
makes these molecules that humans don't
make very well and and so we need those
in and those are actually made by your
bacteria but maintaining humming
astatically in your body and when these
things when your bacteria get out of
sync or when you aren't making certain
of these molecules you've become you can
become quite diseased and so there are
very important parts of metabolism or in
this are represented by the gut bacteria
including things like your brain
chemistry so so these are the types of
things that we can measure now this is
this slide is just demonstrating the
development of the technology in over
the past 15 years we've gone through
four wholesale changes of
instrumentation as the instrumentation
got better and better
we now have a platform our basic
technology is on what are called
accurate mass instruments where we can
get down to a measurement of a ten
thousandth of a Dalton and throughout
this whole process we were improving the
software and improving the mathematics
and so everywhere you see Arrowhead on
that timeline is a new software package
that we had to write or an application
or deriving algorithms and what we were
trying to do during that period you can
see down in the lower left corner in
that panel is we were trying to improve
the overall precision of the technology
so we run quality control samples on
every instrument every day and we can
take that data over a year and we can
understand what was the total product
process variants in in a sample
throughout a whole year and you can see
from this inside in 2015 our total
process variance was about four and a
half percent and in that point in time
we were measuring about two thousand
molecules and so it is a very highly
precise technology and to put that in
context if you're measuring blood sample
through LabCorp request they shoot at
being able to have a total process
varying some about ten percent they
often return data at fifteen to twenty
percent and so you can kind of put that
in context we're much better than a
clinical diagnostic precision and that's
what now has opened up our ability to
look at precision medicine so basically
what we're doing is we're screening
through human biochemistry and this is
one of our maps of human bio chemistry
has been curated for reactions that
happen in humans and we're looking for
the area of metabolism that is being
affected in a particular experiment or
in the disease and now what so that's
the basic technology and now what I'm
going to do is switch over to some
applications that we've developed over
the years to show you some of the uses
and in how we have used it to work and
so this first study I'm going to explain
was a collaboration between our group at
metabolite researchers led by Carson
sori at Helmholtz Institute in Munich
and by Kenneth E Specter at King's
College in London and the question on
this technology are this this approach
this case study was you know could we
map allylic variants of DNA could we map
these mutations to changes that they
might cause in biochemistry and so to
answer that question we had to to large
population studies with the munich group
we had 768 individuals with the king's
college group we had a thousand and
fifty six individuals and they have what
at the time and this was about five or
six years ago was a saturation sniff
analysis with six between 650 and
550,000 snips
each person there was an overlap of
those two databases or two data sets of
about 450,000 data points so you know we
had pretty good saturation snip coverage
throughout the genome and what we were
looking for is could we draw an
association between those allelic
variants and changes that happened in
metabolism in the blood and to do that
to be called a positive you would have
to get an association that was above a
bond Peroni correction in both datasets
and so it had to be positive in the
German group in positive and the British
group and in doing that study we came up
with about 37 associations and we
published this in nature a number of
years ago and about half of those
associations were two previously unknown
gene functions and so they were mapping
orphan genes that no one had known what
that gene had done before we were we had
run this study and and that may seem
like a small number it actually seems
like a very large number to me and my
logic would be that in order to to be
scored positive you're allylic frequency
in both a German population and in a
British population is going to have to
be quite high so not you can't have a
little that's just in a German
population or just in a British
population because it won't show up
statistically in both and then on top of
the allelic frequency you have to have a
little like a fact that's very high
because we're not going to see that a
little very often and so the effect that
it makes on metabolism is going to have
to be high so I was surprised that we
actually had 37 and if you go into this
paper and into the Supplemental data and
there's about a hundred pages of
supplemental data behind this
publication you can see that there were
about 200 of these associations that did
not get above the statistical cutoff but
we knew that a lot of them were correct
because we knew what some of those genes
did you know they would have been
identified genes and so we knew we were
mapping to allylic variants and known
genes and we just weren't getting above
the cutoff and so what we all deduce
from that was we needed to test more
people and so in a follow-up study that
was published a couple of years
we were able to extend that to 8,000
subjects and now we were able to get
those numbers up to 145 associations and
among those 145 genes 80 of them were
actually new genes that we didn't have a
previous function for so this is a way
you know we were seeing that this is a
way to effectively map gene function and
really now in this experiment and you
can see this in the Supplemental and now
data behind this paper that there were
2,000 associations that didn't get above
the statistical cutoff and we know that
a lot of those were right because we
know what those genes do and we knew
that we were actually mapping a lot of
other genes but again we're being
limited by the population that we're
testing and so in the past year we've
run 50,000 patients we've done two
things actually
we run 50,000 patients and that analysis
is going on now and we think we're going
to really push this association very
high theoretically we probably need to
do 500,000 individuals in order to get
all the genes mapped in humans but this
is going to really change what we know
about biology the other thing we've done
and this was in collaboration with human
longevity and Craig Venters group and
also Tim specters group at King's
College as they went in and did whole
genome sequencing on the entire twins
cohort and weari measured all those
twins and we pushed this number of 145
to about 300 and why that has gone up is
because now we're not limited to the
snips that we're seeing on snip chips
we're actually mapping allelic variants
that aren't on snip chips and so it
becomes a much denser data set of
allelic frequency and so then that paper
is submitted now and we expect it to be
published this year so we believe that
you know testing enough people and this
in this approach will be able to map
pretty much every gene in humans that
has anything to do with metabolism which
is going to be quite a lot of them and
so basically the conclusions from that
is you can measure a little difference
individuals and those will cause
metabolic variations in subjects and you
can use this as a mapping technique and
so we're very excited about where this
is headed and we're applying this now to
large population studies in various
countries and we think that we could hit
that number 500,000 and in a few years
so you know that's one type of
application and as we were developing
this analysis we also started working
with art the dets group at Baylor
College of Medicine and at the time art
was the chair of the department of
genetics at Baylor and art is a very
well-known scientist and inherited
metabolic disease so he's essentially
added the tech edited the textbook on
inherited metabolic diseases used
throughout the world in medical schools
and on and what art has spent most of
his career on is really understanding
the inborn errors of metabolism in
inherited metabolic disease and to
understand this problem you got to go
back more than a hundred years and so in
1909 in London Archibald Garrod working
at Saint Bart's Hospital proposed that
there would be changes in the individual
changes and individuals in their
chemistry that would then lead to
disease and he called that inborn errors
of metabolism and that little box is
actually the front page of his paper and
that was a very forward-thinking paper
it's a fantastic paper if you ever want
to go back and read that but those
inborn errors of metabolism and the work
that was done over the next hundred
years has led to testing of every child
in the developed world are almost every
child in developed world for these types
of problems because in these N born
errors they're reasonably rare diseases
but if you can identify the disease
early there you can intervene and you
can stop the development of a lot of
very serious clinical problems and so
these babies are typically at birth they
are given a hill prick test so they put
a little blood spot on the card and send
that in to a public health care lab and
then at the public healthcare lab
leaves they have a positive they will
refer that patient to a genetics
department like Baylor College of
Medicine if you're in Texas so there's
just give you an example there are 39
public health labs in the United States
that do this typically run by States and
there's about a hundred and fifty
genetic centers that these cases get
referred to an arts problem is that if
he gets a case over the years they've
done the analysis on this and it cost
about five thousand to ten thousand
dollars to get a diagnosis on a patient
and it can take a long time which is not
a good thing and it can take a lot of
sample and so it's it's hard to get a
lot of sample from from a disease child
so you know we we thought we could do
better and he thought we could do better
and so we set up a study and in this
study he sent us 200 patients and he
sent us blood urine and these these
patients were blinded to us and what art
said is they're all confirmed patients
some of them don't have a disease
some of them do have a disease and what
he wanted us to do is identify those
that were diseased versus those that
were healthy and then tell him what
disease they had and so that was our
challenge and we did we took on that
study and in fact we were able to do
very well on it of those 200 we called
all 70 unaffected cases as being
unaffected and we called 129 diseases of
130 correctly correctly as well in the
only case that we missed was a patient
who was currently on therapy and his
disease was being treated and it was
effectively being treated patient didn't
have any symptoms and his metabolism was
being maintained okay
so effectively we called every case
correctly if you this is a slide that
shows those types of diseases so in that
original study there were about 29
different types of diseases and for
example with three MCC there were only
four cases of 200 that we saw we call
all four cases correctly and we didn't
call anyone else with the disease that
didn't
the disease and so what was a hundred
percent sensitivity and specificity now
the way we could do this is by
understanding metabolism and so what we
did with that data set is we created a
data set of the 200 patients and we
could establish a mean for the
concentration of every molecule that we
were measuring and then we could
establish what the standard deviation
away from the mean was and then we could
take the patients and for every molecule
we would give a numerical score for
every molecule that was outside one and
a half standard deviations from the mean
and then what we could do is start
valuing pathways and so we could add up
those values of molecules in a metabolic
pathway and then score the pathway and
then we could roll those pathways up
into bigger pathways and finally into
super pathways to get an answer on what
was happening with the patient and this
is a typical result so this is a single
patient's data and these are the super
pathways of human biochemistry and so
what you're looking at is this patient
is normal in everything except for
nucleotide biosynthesis and if we go to
the pathways that comprise nucleotide
biosynthesis he actually this patient is
affected in every one of them and we can
then look at all the other pathways of
metabolism and it's actually all only
those pathways that lead into nucleotide
biosynthesis that this patient has been
effective in and when we look at the
molecules that it's causing this to
happen these are the molecules here and
the only thing that comes in common of
all these molecules and pathways is the
enzyme primatene phosphorylase and so
from this type of a sort of mathematical
analysis you could identify that the
mutation or the child had to be
defective and diamondium phosphorylase
and in this case it had been proven
through sequencing that he was and so
this was a you know a positive call now
we needed to make this easier and so
what we did is develop a visualization
technique for this and this is looking
at a diseased patients data and we've
got this now cast on to
map of human biochemistry and so this
map has been highly curated for only
pathways that exist in humans and
whereas a lot of the maps they're about
most of those map sources are at least
five to ten percent wrong they have
pathways in them that do not exist in
humans so we've gone through all of that
and really curated what is in humans and
what's not and that's what you're
looking at here and now the
visualization that works this way so if
you have a colored circle the molecule
is at least one and a half standard
deviations away from the mean if it's up
it's got red circle and if it's down
it's got a blue circle and then the size
of the circle it is proportional to the
number of standard deviations away from
the mean and so you can see various
sizes there now one and a half standard
deviations if you think of a Gaussian
curve twenty percent of your values are
going to be outside of one and a half
standard deviations so you're gonna be
seeing a lot of noise and that's what
you're seeing through here and we wanted
to be able to see that baseline of noise
in order to be able to value whether a
signal was actually coming through and
so what you're seeing here is the basic
noise of the metabolism in this patient
and when you look up in that upper
left-hand corner you see bigger cluster
of changes and when we bring this up
this is actually branch chain key branch
chain amino acid catabolism and so
you're looking at leucine isoleucine and
valine and how they're being catabolized
in this patient and we're accumulating
all the molecules above this rectangle
and we're decreasing the molecules below
that and that rectangle is
representative of the enzyme branch
chain keto acid dehydrogenase and it's
well known that a mutation in that
enzyme can cause the disease maple syrup
urine disease and so this is a
representation of maple syrup urine
disease patient and every time we see
that disease we're going to see this
pattern now the reason that's important
is because there are a lot of mutations
in that enzyme that can cause this
disease and they those mutations vary in
penetrants they bury in their time and
when they're going to present and they
vary at their severity but no matter how
they vary they're going to look like
this this pattern and so we can think of
these now changes as being variables and
we can take those variables and assign
them values and then derive equations
about that and this would be a typical
disease score equation for maple syrup
urine disease and these men these
equations since they're multivariate
become very very sensitive for the
disease and very very specific and so we
don't really even have to visualize the
data we can run the equations through
the data and be able to identify these
patients with a hundred percent
sensitivity and specificity and were
much more sensitive than existing
technologies and so what that has led to
to a development of a product we develop
this Co develop this with Baylor we call
it meta IMD at Baylor they call it
global maps and whatnot IND does is we
can take a small sample from a patient
about a hundred microliters of blood
plasma and we can now assess about 65
different diseases in that one sample
and we can do that within about 10 days
and we hope eventually to get that down
to five but even at ten days that's very
quick for being able to reach a
diagnosis on these patients and so what
you're seeing here is a patient and
they're within a normal range on all of
these pathways that are green in the one
pathway that they're out of the normal
range is shown there when you kind of
blow that up that disease is Arjun
anemia and if you flip to the next page
this is what arginine this is what the
patient looks like that they got very
high expression on certain molecules
very low expression on others and this
is the pathway that's being affected and
it's very clear to people that study
inherited metabolic disease that this
would be arginine emia and so this is a
product that we're now offering to the
genetic labs across the country that do
this follow up diagnosis we're also
going to move this in the pediatric care
later you know we're trying to get the
groots on first so this is a typical
thing that you can do with the
technology and there are a number of
these types of diseases we think we can
get this list of diseases up to about
200 within the next year or two and so
it's going to be a fantastic way of
really taking a small sample and being
able to assess whether they might have a
disease and this is important I mean
people think you could do just need a
sequencing but the DNA sequencing data
can be very ambiguous and for several
reasons and even though life you took an
enzyme like phenylalanine hydroxylase
that causes PKU we know there's 222
alleles have been proven to cause that
disease in phenylalanine hydroxylase
some of them cause a very severe form of
the disease some causes a very weak form
of the disease sometimes the penetration
is early in life sometimes it's going to
be later in life and then there's 3,000
alleles that are possible better beside
those 222 and we don't know what they do
and that's either because possibly
they've been embryonic defective and so
you didn't have a maybe result from that
mutation or they could be just silent
mutations and they don't do anything or
they could just be not well
characterized
and so the sequencing data can be quite
ambiguous but the actual metabolic data
is quite specific so that's that's
another type of use of the technology
and then in kind of the last case study
I'm going to show is coming from Tom
Cassidy and his colleagues at Baylor
College of Medicine and what our our
plan with Tom was is he published a
paper on the young presidential
organization cohort about three years
ago where he did whole exome sequencing
on 80 individuals that were
self-reported healthy and I think
they're finding rate was about 15% of
those patients had a genetic issue that
needed to be brought to the attention of
the patient and brought to the attention
of the physician and that was a really
cornerstone page paper now for the use
of genomic data in patient care and so
Tom sent us those 80 patients again
blinded and the challenge here was could
we could we find anything in that
patient cohort that wasn't found
genetically and so we looked through
those 80 patients and one of the
patients this is patient 3905 in this
patient you can see the data the open
circles are the spread of those 80
patients in the date of the the red is
the actual patient we're discussing here
and this patient has very high levels of
sorbitol and high levels of fructose and
this would be impacted indicative of a
genetic disorder called fructose
intolerance and precut intolerance is
caused by a mutation in the aldolase b
gene and so you know our interpretation
of this patient was okay we picked up a
fructose intolerant patient so there
should be a corresponding mutation now
at least beep so we went back to Tom and
asked him if that actually was the case
and he couldn't find it being reported
to him in the data and that's when we
started digging into okay what do
positions get to see in the data and so
what had happened is they run a series
of algorithms through this data and
aldolase be just wasn't considered it
wasn't deemed to be an important
mutation and actually it wasn't even
reported as a mutation so we went back
and Tom went back to the original
sequencing data they looked at the al
beliefs B gene and there was in fact a
mutation it was actually a very
conserved notation so it was a change
from an ISO loosing to valine which most
people would think wouldn't do anything
and so there was a mutation there the
computer program had just rendered it to
be benign
and so it wasn't being reported even
though that mutation has never been seen
in the history of science
it was rated by the programs as benign
so they called the patient back in this
was a female kind of middle aged and
started asking her about her medical
history you know they asked her if she
was a purpose of Tolerance she said she
didn't know what that meant and then
they asked her if she ate certain kinds
of fruits and laid out what those fruits
were and she said I don't know I
couldn't eat those fruits you know they
caused severe abdominal distress but I
eat something like that it's been
happening since I was a child
that's fructose intolerance and so here
well
we have as the metabolism able to pick
up a genetic disorder that's actually
been missed by the DNA sequencing in the
computer programs actually the
sequencing saw the mutation had just
didn't value it as being important so
that's one type of patient we had this
is another patient example so this is
39:23 and in this case we didn't have a
medical finding on this patient at all
but Tom came back and said well there
must be a mistake because the the DNA
sequence is showing a deleterious
mutation in xanthine dehydrogenase and
it's saying that this is a disease
allele and it should be causing xanthine
urea now if you had xanthine urea you
would have very high levels of -
xanthine and xanthine and very low
levels of your 8 and that's really not
what you're seeing in this patient so
this patient looks totally normal and so
we went back in ask Tom the question you
know why do you why is this patient
being reported and this is actually the
cm-12 8:35 for is the allele number that
the patient had we went back into the
literature to look at why that was
considered as a mutation and it all
comes back to a single publication and a
single patient that's being reported and
so there's really not not a high degree
of confidence that we actually number
one have a disease G have a disease
mutation or that we understand anything
about its penetrance and so in the
meantime Tom's collaborators went back
to that patient they isolated the enzyme
xanthine dehydrogenase and could show
that it was perfectly active and so this
is another type of thing where we're
looking at biochemistry were able to
either confirm or disconfirm whether in
a little is penetrant and we will be
coming out in the next year working with
Tom and working with HLI showing that
hundreds of cases of us where we have a
putative mutation and we've been able to
show it either is penetrant through the
metabolism or it's not penetrating to
the metabolism and so we think this is
going to be another use of the
technology that's going to be very
important as we start to progress
through
of genomic medicine now we were also
picking out things that weren't
genetically determined or probably
weren't genetically determined and so
these are two patients and what we have
here is evidence of acetaminophen
induced liver toxicity and so
acetaminophen is Tylenol since we're
measuring all the molecules in a sample
we see all these changes and these in
this upper set of panels are the
metabolites of acetaminophen and you can
see that these patients are very high in
their littlez of acetaminophen
metabolites if you get down to the
second bracket of measurements these are
secondary bile acids and so in our work
with about 70 different patient cohorts
and liver disease
the secondary bile acids are actually
the earliest and best indicator of the
onset of liver disease and what you see
is in patient 3958 you really don't see
any indication of liver disease looks
pretty normal in in patient 39 76 he's
starting this patient is starting to
display liver disease and if you drop
down to that last line that's
glutathione and the protective mechanism
in the liver to protect against
acetaminophen toxicity is the
accumulation of diam and in patient 39
76 where the showing signs of liver
disease he's depleted in glutathione in
39 58 where he's actually protecting
against liver disease he has very high
levels of glutathione and so this is the
actual reason why we're seeing this
difference now both of these patients
were called in you know during the study
and you know ask the question do you
take tylenol they both said no they were
asked if they take acetaminophen they
both said no and then they were shown
the placard that's in a lot of doctors
offices valio over-the-counter products
that contain acetaminophen and they were
both taking tylenol at night to help
them so I mean a nyquil at night to help
themselves get to sleep so you know both
of these patients have come off of that
now and you know we're actually in a
process of developing disease and so
when you summed up what we were able to
see in the patients we had a 28% hit
rate the medical problem in a
self-reported healthy cohort and so
those
self-reported health East 28 percent of
them actually weren't that healthy and
that's where we started understanding
that the technology had really gotten to
a point and we had tested enough
patience and built enough databases then
we were actually starting to see basic
problems in human health and so I'll
just end with an area where we're
heading and that's looking at health and
wellness and so this is a patient MD
ph.d we're typically still just working
with physicians essentially witness
technology we haven't offered this as a
product yet but you can see where we
went ahead we've taken a hundred
microliters the plasma sample we've
assayed now about 900 molecules in this
individual and relative to a population
that's relevant for this individual he's
showing signs of early stage chronic
disease now this patient self-reported
is healthy we went back to him and said
well you know you don't look that
healthy and in fact you know as we dug
into his medical history he was
pre-diabetic pre-diabetics to typically
think of themselves as healthy and we
were picking that up with our diabetes
markers this is a score that's derived
from about 31 molecules that we know
associate type-2 diabetes the showing
signs of early stage cardiovascular
disease and various other problems and
so you know these are the types of
things we're now doing with our
technology and you know where we're
headed and so with that I'm going to end
thank you for watching this webcast and
would be happy to entertain questions I
guess and you know thanks a lot for your
attention
oops I'm sorry no technical difficulty
there you couldn't hear me I was saying
thank you to dr. Roz for not informative
presentation and before we get started
on the question-and-answer session I
want to remind our audience how would
you submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button in the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can
hey dr. Ross our first question is how
would you order how do my order IMD any
of these tests especially something like
meta I meta IMD you really need to go
through a position we're a CLIA lab in a
cap based lab so we can report
information back to physicians but the
position has to really be the interface
with the patient and so we are offering
this through a lot of genetic
institutions across the country and so
the best thing to do right now is these
are contact Baylor directly which we can
get those samples through Baylor or go
to your nearest human genetics
department your nearest medical school
or get your pediatrician to do that and
we we can get it through those those
groups
Jethro's you've shown that there are
about 2,000 molecules that you can
measure in humans I've seen much larger
numbers why the discrepancy vestigators
not really understanding the difference
for example between ion features and
data points and actually what molecules
are and so I showed early on that there
even just using our four methods we can
measure at least a hundred and sixty
thousand data points of those data
points probably only about ten thousand
of them represent real molecules and so
I think there's a major misunderstanding
of what that data represents it's coming
out of mass spectrometers an ion feature
does not equate to a unique molecule a
molecule can present fifty to a hundred
different molecules I mean a hundred
different ion features so I think it's
just a major misrepresentation now we
have done a huge amount of research on
this number 2000 and so we've gone
through the human genome and we've
looked at every enzyme that could
possibly cause a biochemical reaction in
humans you know if you do that and you
try to estimate the number of enzymes
you can come up with about 1,500
molecules we can go at it through
looking at every molecule has ever been
reported homeostatic aliy in a human in
medical textbooks and biochemistry books
and we can add those numbers in and and
what our number represents is the number
of homeostatic regulated molecules and
so when people throw out these very
large numbers they may be referring to
the fact that not every person is going
to have that molecule so if you ate
something weird one day you might have
molecules in your blood that we don't
really see in anyone else so we wouldn't
consider that to be part of human
metabolism that's that's single biotic
and if you added all the xenobiotic
measurements you might get to those
numbers but those rarely are going to
correlate with disease states especially
chronic diseases
and so I think there's just a lot of
misunderstanding that's being bannard
around by furnaces my mass spectrometry
that don't really have a great great
understanding of metabolism dr. Rao's
can you share with us what's next on the
horizon or the travel on an Asian
medicine sure so that's a great question
so one of the areas that were really
interested in right now one is that we
think we have a breakthrough in chronic
fatigue syndrome and again that is a
disease that affects about 3 million
Americans it's characterized by a
continuous fatigue state we've done some
pretty large studies on this and we
believe we now have the actual signature
for that and actually relates to energy
molecules and a depression of energy
molecules and we can actually get at why
it's happening and so by looking at all
the metabolism that we it's not just
that we can see the chronic fatigue we
can actually understand why the
metabolism has been perturbed in order
to cause that to happen so this is
something that we're trying to
understand you know how do we get this
out to affected patients we think
probably by the end of the year we'll
have that figured out but it's a very
interesting and very important area
we've also been very active in
undiagnosed disease and so undiagnosed
disease it's about 6 million Americans
that's estimated a lot of these are
going to be inherited metabolic
disorders that have just previously been
yes we've done a lot of undiagnosed
disease patients as well and I think you
know we are making breakthroughs in that
area as well and so these are two areas
where I'm sure we're going to be able to
have an impact and we're just getting
the data assimilated scientifically to
you know to prove that we have medical
validity and utility and then you know
we'll be offering those types of
analysis as well
I would like to once again thank dr.
John riles for his presentation and also
our audience for their participation
dr. Wiles you have any final comments
for audience well yeah I'd like I mean
I've just I think you could tell I mean
we're all very excited about the
technology and where we're headed with
metabolomics we think this is going to
be a major technological advance in
order to understand disease states and
health and wellness states better and
we're just very excited about where
we've gotten to and where we're headed
so you know thank you all for tuning in
and you know thanks for your attention
thank you again dr. Rous I would also
like to thank our sponsor lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 23rd 2017 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available replay we
invite you to format that key
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event we need
thank you for joining us and hope to see
you again thank you goodbye